If you ever wondered how creators are
making ads that look like $100,000
productions, well, let me be the one to
tell you that it's all done using AI.
And you're not going to believe me when
I say this, but these videos use just
one tool and one text prompt to do it.
Now, right off the bat, we've got some
really creative ads to show you. So, you
can start visualizing how you can use
this for your brand. And it's incredibly
easy to do and customize, just like this
insane Tesla video. And again, we also
have this really funny Uber Eats one
made by Mentor over on Twitter. Check
this out.
>> But yo, what if you want some real earth
food, though? That's when you hit up
Uber Eats, my guy. Pizza, burgers,
sushi.
>> Now, in this video, I'm going to give
you a few real world use cases so you
can start visualizing how you can create
your very own. I'm then going to explain
the entire process to create these
prompts. And then we're actually going
to go ahead and create these videos.
Now, we're going to be using my own
custom workflow to customize these
prompts. so you can create exactly what
you want. And I'm also going to give you
access to 10 different prompts that you
can use right away to create some of
these videos. So, be sure to stay tuned
for that. Now, before we jump into all
of it, if you're new to AI and want to
actually learn how to use all the best
AI tools to create content for yourself
or even your brand, or you just want to
stay ahead of the curve, then make sure
to check out my AI community down below.
But all that said and done, let's go
ahead and jump right into it. So, just
to simplify things, I found this really
cool thread on Twitter which gives a
bunch of different examples that you can
go ahead and look through. We also leave
a link to this in the description if you
want to check it out. But if we go ahead
and click play, you can see we've got
two examples right here. We've got the
Tesla one and then we've got the Apple
Watch one. And you can see that they
just look immaculate. Like they look
like real CGI VFX videos, which would
literally cost $100,000. If you go ahead
and scroll down a little bit, we've got
another Tesla one, and this one just
looks like a showroom. It looks
absolutely amazing. But if we go ahead
and scroll down a little bit further,
you can start to see that we're getting
the Jason prompts that we talked about.
So this is a Pepsi ad and you can kind
of imagine this being shown at like the
Super Bowl or something. It looks really
good. Then we've got another Apple Watch
one and you can see that it's using the
logo and the actual Apple Watch itself
looks like the real Apple Watch, which
is absolutely crazy. And this isn't done
by using any images. It's all done using
JSON prompts, which you can see looks
like this. And as you can tell, it looks
pretty complicated, but trust me, I'm
gonna explain what this is, and it's
going to simplify it for you so much
more, and you're gonna be like, "Oh,
that's not hard at all." To finish off,
I wanted to show you this Dior one. It
looks really cool. Obviously, Dior is a
perfume, and it has all of the flower
scents and etc. It just looks really,
really good. So, I wanted to show you
some of these use cases so you can start
to imagine how you can incorporate your
own products when it comes to creating
ads like this. Now in order to create
these videos you can of course use
native text prompting but to get the
best results and what all these creators
using is something called JSON
prompting. Now JSON prompting is a
method of structurizing your prompts
using a JSON format which basically just
defines your roles and instructions. So
it kind of makes the AI analyze this
text and it uses readable tokens. So it
makes it easier for the AI to understand
exactly what you want without using any
fluff words like and also add the
environment to this um and do this but
don't do this etc etc. So you kind of
get the point. So to give you a good
example of what a text prompt would look
like in VO and adjacent prompt I
actually found a really great example
from Tim Simmons. So shout out to him.
So first up we have a video which uses
just text prompts. So let's go ahead and
play that. She left me. But I'll have my
revenge. I'm going to find that man in a
blue business suit and make him pay.
>> Now, as you just saw, the video does
look really good. Don't get me wrong,
but it definitely doesn't live up to
that cinematic style that I showed you
at the start of this video. So, now
let's go ahead and play a video using
Jason prompting.
>> She left me, but I'll have my revenge.
I'm going to find that man in a blue
business suit and make him pay. Now, as
you can see, that looks way better. And
I'm going to go ahead and put both
videos side by side, so you can compare
them visually together. But right off
the bat, you can see that the Jason
prompting just looks way more cinematic
and actually something like you would
see in a real ad. So, now that you have
a basic understanding of what Jason
prompting is, I'm going to go ahead and
show you how you can create your very
own super easily using this method. So,
I put together a resource that you can
get in the description down below. And
if you're using Chat GPT or Gemini, you
can create dedicated gems or projects.
So you can create your prompts in
literally 5 seconds. I'm not even
joking. So I'm going to be using Chat
GPT. And if you've got a subscription,
you can go ahead and create projects. I
definitely recommend you do this because
it'll make your workflow so much easier.
So here you can see that we have
instructions and project files. So
basically, whenever you prompt anything
inside of here, it's basically going to
take your instructions and your project
files. And the instructions look
something like this. And then the file
is basically a file with a bunch of JSON
examples which is going to take as
reference to create our prompts. So if I
go ahead and ask chat GPT create a JSON
prompt for a Tesla ad, you'll see that
it then puts our text. And then if we go
ahead and hit generate, you're going to
see that it spits out a perfectly
crafted JSON prompt. So all you have to
do is basically just prompt it what you
want. And if you have a product of your
image, you can add your own image and
say this is a product of my image. It
basically does XY Z. Can you go ahead
and create a JSON prompt? If you have an
idea of what you want, you could say I
want the let's say it's a bottle of
shampoo. I want the shampoo to start
hovering in the bathroom and then I
don't know, you just tell it what you
want and it will do it. But here you can
see we have our JSON prompt. So it's
been perfectly crafted. So once you have
that, you want to go ahead and click on
copy. And now we're going to go ahead
and create our video. So you want to
start off by heading over to
flow.google. This is going to give us
access to voree. Now if you don't have
access to this, it is a paid tool. I'm
going to quickly show you how you can
get it for completely free. So go ahead
and open up a new tab and then just type
in Gemini AI Pro. And then you want to
make sure you're clicking on this
Gemini. Google and make sure it goes to
subscriptions. And then here you can see
if you scroll down you have access to
Google AI pro for completely free for 1
month. And they've just recently added
Flow which gives you access to VO free.
Now you get a,000 credits using this
plan. It's free. So what this means is
you can generate 10 videos in high
quality or you can generate over I think
100 or a,000 videos. I'm not entirely
sure. It uses 20 credits um using the
slow mode which is 720p. So once you've
gone ahead and gotten access come back
to flow, click on create with flow. Then
you're going to come on this page right
here. It's as simple as clicking new
project. And then if you've copied your
prompt, go ahead and paste it in just
like that. Now, quickly before you hit
generate, make sure you're using V3 fast
because this uses only 20 credits. The
downside is it's 720p. So to access
this, go to settings, go to models, and
then use V3 fast, not V2 because V2 will
not generate audio, but V3 will. If you
do want a high quality one, then use the
quality setting here. Just make sure
it's the one that says beta audio. Then,
if you want to maximize on your credits
and not spend too many, change your
output to one. We're just going to go
ahead and click two because it only cost
20 credits and we're on the ultra plan,
so we've got a bunch of credits. Now, if
we go ahead and hit generate, you'll see
that the videos are going to start
loading. So, let's go ahead and skip
forward so I can show you these videos.
And as you saw, that looks amazing. We
basically gave it a simple prompt and it
created all of this, which is absolutely
mind-blowing. If you think back to 2022
when we were getting videos that look
like this, and now we're in 2025 and
we're getting full-blown $100,000
productions using a simple prompt, you
will not believe me. Now, of course, if
you're using the fast mode, I said it's
720p video, but the upside is you can
actually go ahead and click on download,
and then you can upscale it to 1080p.
And of course, if you have access to a
video upscaler or a third party one, you
can upscale that over to 4K. So, then
you get even higher quality. Now, if you
want to start creating videos right away
and you don't want to go ahead and use a
chat GPT workflow, what we're going to
do is in the description down below,
there'll be a Google Docs link, which
gives you access to 10 different prompts
so you can start creating videos like
these right away. Now, if you found this
video helpful, then be sure to like and
subscribe for more awesome AI updates.
And again, if you want to learn how to
master all the best AI tools, then be
sure to check out the private community
down below. I'll see you in the next